hey ask embrace my name is beautiful
today it's a very crazy day I didn't
think they'd say would happen you've
read the title The Last Guardian I get
to play it oh oh hey I just needed to
say that I've been giving this last the
last card the Last Guardian I've been
giving it access early according to you
as guidelines I am required to say that
thank you we did the Shadow of the
Colossus on this channel it's one of my
favorite games this is made by the same
creator they announced this game I don't
know how long ago i pre-ordered this
game back when I was still in Sweden
about 6 years ago and I want my 50
Swedish crowns back thank you very much
I'm gonna go back to that game stop I
remember your smug ass face game stop
guy but regardless it's ok it's ok it's
ok I'm here I get to play the Last
Guardian I'm so [ __ ] excited I say
that a lot when I play a game that I'm
really excited by but this one has to be
the top one so far I've been refusing to
watch any gameplay footage of this
because I just want the real experience
and I don't know let's just get into the
game I'm just so [ __ ] pumped Jesus
Christ that's a hippopotamus
I think yep I wasn't expecting this
oh that's it I think that's Edgar as a
fetus
great what oh jeez say
Shadow the Colossus is one of those
games that even if you play it today it
still has an age I mean obviously it has
age but it's still [ __ ] awesome all
right here we go all right he went this
way but I kind of want to explore and
learn the controls the lava so I can
trip over which seems like a useful
feature
all right sneaking I'm [ __ ] stupid I
can do a little jumpy Jew all the
controls are amazing the animations
that's so cool like if I'll move the
other way he falls that way and if I
jump this way oh that's so cool I don't
know how to explain it but Danny Mason's
are really cool I'm told that the
creator of the game is action animated
himself that it actually makes sense I
think I can get into it
hey how you doing there buddy don't eat
me please it's a man bear burger okay
cool
we're best friends right all right what
do we do what is he doing he pulled on
the gate for me what are you doing stop
the heck what does he do it oh my god is
like having Edgar what is your problem
Jesus crying
all right nice little burp there thank
you very much okay I guess he wants me
to swing from it
let's go up here it's just so [ __ ]
cool okay dude I was just about to jump
on that the hell is your problem well I
didn't really work out did it let's try
that again there we go all right I don't
know why I struck over that so much
don't touch it right now please
that'd be really bad for me oh cool
all right here we go that's awesome now
don't die please yay
all right oh oh no I can't tell if he's
with me or not I scares me that's all I
know
all right let's go up here what is this
temple marina Joyce is gonna come out
Bowl never okay I can do that
[Music]
I did that I did that all by myself
thank you for it very much very proud of
that little flame thing I did there
oh my god he really doesn't like or does
he I'm so scared it's beautiful
why is he looking at me like spank me
pits why do I always have to get
sexually I'm sorry this is keep playing
I don't want to ruin this beautiful game
what if I jump on him come on jump on
him Oh grab on buddy
alright I'm so scared hold on
why aren't you my holding on oh [ __ ] I
think Ryback I'm so cute I look like a
little jacksepticeye alright calm down
calm down buddy oh Jesus Christ
that thing is talking you alright just
jump up it's like what why what's that
somebody's got my ass okay here we go
now I grab down to him and I grab on by
holding eggs now let's go baby
up there don't do this at home here we
go come on
come on buddy he's got it tight awake so
cute oh hey there boy I am that's my
stuff thank you very much I'm out of
here
Jesus Christ there we go let go jump
nailed it nailed it
so easy not a problem all right
we're probably gonna let something else
I imagine what we're going here okay
cool
don't need you hi oh another puzzle I
guess I'm supposed to jump over here
dude Jesus Christ he scares the [ __ ] out
of me
do not bar whatever you do to not follow
okay so we could jump dare okay we're
fine we're fine everyone's fine now what
we need to do is hang Oh God are you
[ __ ] high PlayStation what do you
mean let go what are you smoking I'm Ben
just walk it up another lever here okay
great
I feel fantastic those aspirin roots
really work here we go pull the lever I
can do that
dan that one hasn't been pulled in a
while
and the glowing love of one came down
fantastic pick up the glowing lava of
course as you do mamas do I got here so
cool I'm walking with it hey buddy I got
you some favorite snacks some acid what
do I do with this [ __ ] it let's let's go
up here with it
special delivery maybe I'm supposed to
let it go here I think I'm supposed to
let it go alright don't spill the Smurf
juice come on I want to open this there
it is
throw away that's awesome the animation
is amazing [ __ ] that didn't really work
out all right now I [ __ ] the Smurf juice
no no oh my god are you [ __ ] high jay
says crime so bad at this game I realize
this is probably painful I'm trying my
best just know that I'm trying my best
all right I got the Smurfs juice oh you
want the Smurfs juice I know you love
Smurfs juice who wants the Smurfs juice
[ __ ] I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't know
all right here come oh oh that's so cool
hi reminds me of climbing the Colossus
it's cool all right we have this here
now what is he doing wait he's curious
about it
you like it
he likes MuRF juice we're gonna do it's
grabbing it now sorta buddy don't pet my
Smurf juice what's he doing oh geez
do you like it stops mixing I think he
might be allergic of Smurf juice
all right mine no mine no mine stop stop
mine stop no go away now we're gonna all
we're gonna put this mergers here and
let's can open the gate Oh course [ __ ]
wrong button okay hang the pine oh it's
just a pot that wasn't smurf juice
disappointment is that enough for me to
go through no it's not come on buddy
oh he got it he got it come on come on
please please don't eat it what are you
doing stop back that's my chest
oh no oh go go go
yes yeah yeah nail there maybe there's
something I can do here
okay I'll grip this hey calm down a bro
that's not his name I don't know his
name why am I doing this I don't know it
doesn't matter
nailed it nailed it
oh [ __ ] I can go in here okay cool what
do we have here
a bucket of Smurf juice yeah yeah camel
Oh what is this hey buddy look what I
got that's right your favorite you want
Sam oh oh boy
hey buddy look what I got you want this
one
you don't want that one come on man stop
stop you got it you got an addiction you
got a problem
and no no
heater's ate it why did you do that know
what I did all that just for him to eat
it you know cozy up here
oh yeah we you do I'll cure you too - oh
that's interesting
I like that way of storytelling so yeah
they're giving me tips because I'm
taking way too much [ __ ] time
thanks game I appreciate it ah here we
go oh Jesus
there it is push damn it oh there it is
push it more come on you know kuzey OTO
oke oe listen I'm on it
you think I know I think I did it but
not really
come on buddy oh come on this way how
excited I am this way come on buddy
it's a Yeti over here I promise it's
gonna be super cool okay so I'm playing
a lot kind of in the middle of the game
so a lot of stuff isn't explained so
I'll blame that if I'm bad at the game
that's that's not my fault okay I'm
supposed to know stuff I'm climbing his
butthole I'm so sorry terrible idea
all right well [ __ ] it alright we're
through
we're through thank God now I'm gonna
take you up there
thanks H to
let me forward in Swedish from what's
fine come here not come on buddy
it's interesting how we may or may not
listen to me it's just like Edgar if you
have a pet this game will be very
relatable maybe I can just jump ahead oh
that should have been obvious Jesus okay
whatever got here oh the ice Oh
hey you made a party
what's the matter
oh it's akhirin ot eternally
oh you made him are you no coulis
e-meter Oh
Araki in ROC otaku no yeah kissa he's
transfixed and terrified of this artwork
or should we do well it's a grab it
right that's why I sound crappy I really
like how it's not that straightforward
but it also makes it for me while like
while I'm playing it I'm just [ __ ]
terrible nice little foot bath here I
think dipping my feet in the foot bath I
love splash I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay what do you want me to do about it
it's ancient art quick I'm not just
gonna destroy it
whoa Jesus Christ okay
well that took care of that didn't he
all right this one had spiky things on
it so I guess that works better Jesus
Christ let me do that again
whoa that's it but it up it scared oh
look he's not scared anymore that's okay
better now oh it's so cool
oh man it's [ __ ] awesome all right
now now up there please yeah DJ please
oh he's curious about it come on buddy
he's like oh I was just [ __ ] last why
don't you tell me pierce the hell all
right
oh we're both going fantastic that's
what I wanted he's scared again
fine I'll check it out I'll check it out
no worries whoa holy [ __ ] oh my god this
is cool this is a really good ok he's
coming - what are we doing this is
incredible look at that
I'm so glad I'm playing this game right
now okay how you doing buddy
talk to me I know you don't like putts
so [ __ ] you [ __ ] okay so these have
protection on them we can't kill them
just yet I'm on it don't fall down
though Jesus Christ almost died what do
we got here can i push this probably all
right away you go off you go now
stupid glass [ __ ] oh oh oh my god oh my
god better oh man
all right this time when I do it I am
just gonna push it and get the [ __ ]
outta t not be so [ __ ] maybe get a
pair of shoes okay go go go [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I'm fine
and we're fine could you lift me up
buddy I don't think I could do it for me
okay I think that's a yes come on I need
some help give me a hand
all right lo how he puts his hand there
such a cool detail I've never seen that
in a game and then it sounds stupid but
- come on that's cool finally come on
buddy I need your help buddy oh [ __ ] I'm
in so epic
he doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] about me
I just like [ __ ] you I'm out you gotta
give me some leverage to jump on oh no
what is he doing he's crazy oh my god
okay will you save me oh god he's coming
here oh god oh god oh where is he
promise to catch me please oh he's so
cute
okay all right you got me promise you
catch me promise I don't trust this at
all
oh please catch oh my god that is
awesome thanks I'm glad he bit my shirt
and not my arm all right cool
thanks appreciate it all right we're
almost across buddy we're almost a
crutch I know you're scared of those
little weird things don't worry I got
you cutie pie is here this thing seems
stable as hell okay it's super stable of
course just gonna I could drop down I
know that might that seems terrifying
but drop down please
there it is I would never ever ever ever
do that in my life
okay now I think I need to push this no
hey buddies okay okay I got it I got it
I got it oh yeah I'll push this here
it's a little hard oh god oh god oh god
I see what's gonna happen I see what's
gonna happen okay we push you off it's
gonna fall off a ride perfectly see you
later
hey can you save me again that would be
great thank you
shut up we gotta hurry up I think okay
no what no that's a Heil
they're gonna claim I'm still playing
Jesus pray oh no no come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] not part of the pain oh don't
mind me oh my man one your leg come on I
gotta help him
he's not gonna make him he needs to
Smurf juice always fall it go give him
the king
rabbit dammit here
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh there we go we
helped him oh my god this is stress him
in the [ __ ] out
there it is I got you now let's get the
[ __ ] out of here oh hey we did it buddy
don't worry I'm climbing your armpit
that was [ __ ] amazing oh what a rush
what a [ __ ] rush that was awesome
good job buddy you still scare me okay
but you did good and on that note I have
to end that episode there good job
edgert do you did nothing but sleep in
my lap the whole time what [ __ ] you mate
I could totally do that I could do that
way better than he could I would not
save your life and you could not make
more [ __ ] of it anyway Last Guardian
it's finally happening it's so cool to
finally be playing it and it's so
thrilling to play as well I really
really really like it and I can't wait
to play more obviously let me know it if
you want to see more as well thanks so
much I love you guys so much and I'll
see you in the next one as always stay
awesome rest
[Music]
you